children killed whole villages destroyed
and they come from areas around kiev in
the north of the country re-taken by
ukrainian forces who are now discovering
the barbarity of what russian troops
have left behind
and these images of course will now
become the focus of war crime
investigations
it's easy to feel helpless as we witness
the atrocities but we will be exploring
on the program today anything the
international community
can do
so there's lots to consider this morning
with our guests we'll be talking to the
transport secretary grant shaps on the
show today and in just a few moments
we'll also be joined by the shadow
business secretary labour's jonathan
reynolds the ukrainian mp and human
rights lawyer elona scrum has been
meeting french president emmanuel macron
so we'll talk to her live from paris
and we'll also hear from andre klevikov
who is the executive director of the
alliance for public health in ukraine
where those with hiv and tv are
struggling to get the drugs they need to
stay alive
there's also lots on the domestic
political agenda from energy security to
the cost of living we'll be talking to
the conservative mp for rutland and
melton alicia kent
[Music]
hello well lots to discuss
with the situation in ukraine this
morning and of course lots on the
domestic agenda as well with labour
saying it will cut taxes for small
businesses as partner plans to tackle
soaring costs more relief on business
rates than the party says would save a
local pub thousands of pounds a year
well we're joined now by the party
shadow business secretary john f nashua
thank you so much for being with us
today um
it feels right to start with a situation
in ukraine um as
the russian forces withdraw from those
areas around kyiv we are witnessing
what they've left behind civilians
found next to bicycles next to their
shopping bags
we can't show the images of many of the
atrocities but i think it's right to
kind of pause and reflect on
you know the human face of this the cost
of what people are going through this is
sofia she's 13.
she has shrapnel now in her skull
this is just one of the images that we
can bring to people
what should the uk's response to this be
it's bob barrack i understand why you
can't show the images i think
members of parliament people in
responsibility have to view those to see
to see the scale of what we're talking
about i think after
what the world saw in syria where you
know the advent of modern technology
meant we could see images directly from
atrocities that were taking place meant
we knew
these kind of images were possible yet
it's still the threshold from some of
the things i saw last night was a new
level of barbarity i think
what this country's done what what nato
have done in terms of supplying lethal
aid to the ukrainians is obviously the
right thing to have done and i think
that leads to to continue and step up as
we
get to a new phase of this conflict
where the ukrainians are having some
success pushing entrenched russian
positions back but you know what what i
wanted from the chancellor in the spring
statement was almost a sort of
a wartime statement in terms of energy
you know how we were going to make sure
we weren't still as we are right now as
the western community buying substantial
amounts of fossil fuels from russia that
we could use
emergency measures to to lower our gas
demand whether that's energy efficiency
or more electrification or pushing that
i i didn't feel that i think we've got
to understand this is not a short-term
position it's going to go on it's going
to continue
to prepare for that we'll talk about the
details of the energy strategy later but
just to focus purely on
ukraine and russia and you're right to
say that we're still spending an awful
lot of money on oil and gas in europe in
particular you know since the start of
the war i think the eu has spent 18
billion euros on russian oil and gas i
mean any sanctions gonna have an impact
at all when russia is still effectively
being banked by europe well they will
have an effect and they are having an
effect because the the level of
sanctions are very significant certainly
in terms of how the the russian ruble
has effectively recovered
to say that there's two things going on
here we've tried to isolate as the world
community russia from the from the
global economy whilst at the same time
having that dependency now in terms of
oil
the danger is you just go from one
autocratic authoritarian regime to
another so that's not a long-term
solution
russian gas i think there's a bit of
complacency in the uk because
russia got in the main goes to central
europe but of course because of that
countries like norway then supply the uk
so we've got to understand that what is
required is not anything which increases
our dependency long term on fossil fuels
but gets us off that dependency and that
is why there's got to be this
further sprint on renewables there are
things we've got a good story in this
country and offshore wind but on things
like onshore wind a bad story where
we've had effectively a ban in place so
there are other things that can be done
but it's not it can't be going from one
country to another deciding just who's
the most unpalatable this month this
year it's got to be that longer term
conversion to electrification to further
renewables to further nuclear because
that's the only way forward we'll talk
about that a little bit more later the
government's also promised a safe haven
for ukrainian refugees in the uk are
they delivering on that
well i think the rhetoric
after the initial period has been
where it needs to be and the delivery of
that is a further question i think
there's been a huge response from the
british people around this in terms of
people signing up for the halls for
ukrainian scheme
the worry is how how is that feeding
through on the ground the bureaucracy
that's required behind that making sure
people are coming through i don't think
because we've seen in the past few years
some horrible situations would have led
to significant humanitarian flaws i
almost think we're struggling to
understand the sheer scale of this i
mean the figures of people in poland and
romania alone
these are levels of movements of people
in europe that we just haven't seen for
decades and i think when you see what
other countries are coping with and
doing it's hard to say that as of yet we
have met the scale of that challenge so
i hope the government recognises that
and is willing to do more the other
thing we can of course do is to provide
more weaponry you said earlier that you
think that should be stepped up
what exactly do you mean by stepped up
well the first phase of this conflict
has seen a tremendous response from the
ukrainian armed forces using essentially
western train tactics light units with
anti-tank weaponry which has stopped the
advance of russian units but obviously
this is now a different phase as they
retreat and we're obviously seeing
unfortunately
atrocities occur as those forces leave
so that might require a different level
even if russia would see that as an
escalation well i think russia's
position in terms of what they have
already done and what they are doing it
would be a little bit rich of them to
claim escalation on the part or over the
civilized countries i think we've got to
listen very carefully to what the
ukrainians are telling us about the
equipment they need there's a different
balance there maybe in terms of
air defense units and heavier artillery
compared to the lighter units that have
had such brilliant success and a
brilliant performance by the ukrainians
so far but we've got it we've got to
listen to that and respond to that
because frankly i think the sanctions
have had a significant effect on
russia's ability to resupply and keep
the occupation forces in place but what
we are seeing in terms of them leaving
you this is not
i'm afraid it's not the end of the
conflict it's not a peaceful position
we're returning to we've got to
acknowledge that okay well let's uh talk
now about the energy strategy shall we
you mentioned a bit earlier in the
interview um next week we're expecting
the prime minister to unveil it it feels
as if the briefing
today is all about nuclear with the
business secretary saying up to seven
new nuclear plants but of course
that's not going to help families with
their bills now is it and that's going
to take you know 13 to 17 years to for
that energy to come into the stream does
labor support the broad direction of
where the government's moving well we do
support and more nuclear in the system
alongside that further development of
renewables i think the dangers you say
is that whilst that's for the long term
and frankly the the individual
commissioning decisions on nuclear
reactors all depend on the price you can
achieve and that relates very much to
the financing of the media at the right
price to the right thing to do they can
be very expensive if you haven't been
able to get the right deal and the right
private sector partners to do that i
think none of that
should be used as a small screen to get
away from the real issue which is right
now the cost of living is absolutely
extreme energy bills are a huge part of
that the government hasn't done enough
there's no way they can say they've done
enough the scheme they put forward i
think where the chance is offering to
lend us our own money and pay it back
over five years is completely
unrealistic and doesn't meet the scale
of the challenge what we want to do of
course is that windfall taxes off of
people real support 600 pounds for a
third of households off their energy
bills that's the scale of what is
required and whatever the long-term
energy strategy the government unveil it
can't get away from the fact that
they've got to take some action now to
help people i mean something that could
have an impact in the short term is
looking at the supply of oil and gas as
well isn't it and was it the right
decision by the north sea transition
agency to look at this two year
extension of the cambodia oil fields oil
fields license well
domestic gas and oil from the north sea
is a about half our domestic supply at
the minute and that should continue when
no one questions that strategy the
longer term extraction picture for all
fossil fuels around the world has to be
of course governed by will you say that
but at the same time labor has
previously opposed the development of
the cambodia oil field and you're
talking about a windfall tax in the
north sea as well you know if you were
looking at this you might think that
actually labour isn't that happy about
the idea of people
it's got to be governed by small and
it's going to be governed by the
committee on climate change there's no
point as a country having is that right
does it is that is that what you think
you think the priority should be
achieving net zero opposed to bringing
bills there is no point this country
having
a ambitious climate strategy if we're
not going to stick to it and of course
even if people face
huge huge
like difficulties with paying their
bills even if people are having to turn
off their health let's be clear more
domestic supply is about the security of
that supply it's not about the price the
price is set by the global market price
for that so even if we for instance
wanted to go down the route of
extracting a fundamentally larger amount
of oil and gas from the uk that wouldn't
affect the price the only way to affect
the price is to focus on energy
efficiency so people are using less is
to switch to uh domestic cheaper
electrification of heating so it's very
important people understand that point
there is a one thing that's different
about the situation now because of what
russia has done is there's an argument
about substitution of supplies that
would have perhaps come from russia
coming from other parts of the world so
when i say the committee on climate
change has to look at that picture in
the round that is exactly what they will
do but anyone who thinks bills or supply
in the long term can be sold by more
dependence on fossil fuels that is a
mistake you've got to look at the
alternative which is renewables and
nuclear i've got two very short
questions to squeeze in before we have
to let you go firstly david warburton
has had the conservative whip withdrawn
after allegations made in sunday times
now without going into the details
of the case you know he says he's heard
nothing from the
independent complaints and grievance
scheme do you have concerns about the
culture in westminster
well i've read the story and that's all
i know about this particular thing i i
think the vast majority of members of
parliament
work very hard for their constituents
whatever their party affiliation you
know certainly as a front venture for
most of my time in parliament i've been
you know in opposition it's quite you do
quite a lot of work to make sure you're
matching the capacity the government has
in the civil service i think there are
in any uh sector i've worked in whether
that's the legal sector or politics i
think there are people who sometimes
you know aren't balancing the
responsibilities and the burdens on them
in the right way and they sometimes you
know that gets them into trouble and
behavior they shouldn't do but i don't
think politics is any different in my
experience to other high pressured
sectors in relation to how people behave
okay and finally just summarize will you
um the tax policy that you want to try
and enhance today well the cost of
living is extreme the government isn't
doing enough and people will be better
off under labour so that's because we
wouldn't have proceeded with the
national insurance rise it's because we
would have done that windfall tax to
help people with their energy bills it's
because on business rates which is a
huge expense for business we would have
frozen the valuations we would have
increased the threshold at which
businesses paid business rates so the
average pub or hairdresser on top of
what the government have done would be
around two to three thousand pounds
better off so we do real help for people
now and that's what would make a
difference okay that's the labour pitch
then uh we'll get the government pitch
uh in just a few moments uh time but
thank you for being on the program today
thank you
so that was uh jonathan reynolds well
let's turn to the government now shall
we i can speak to the transport
secretary grant shap thank you very much
for being on the program today
um
it's only right to start with the
situation in ukraine uh as these russian
troops retreating from the areas around
kiev we've been confronted with the true
horrors
of what has happened
how do we respond
to what we're seeing
yeah and i've been speaking to my
opposite number last night alexander
kubrickov who's the infrastructure man
uh minister in ukraine he's in chief uh
he was describing uh some of those uh
scenes from his colleagues and
the world uh cannot just look the other
way
i mean i think it's actually a terrible
wake-up call for the world both in terms
of uh what putin has done and human
rights and the suffering and also as
your previous interviewer was just
saying uh with the
supply of energy to the west which is
largely funding and continues to fund
fund this war effort so um horrendous
our hearts are with everybody uh
involved they are in very
considering what's going on talking to
my ministerial opposite kubokov um he is
very very determined uh actually uh
wanted to speak to me last night about
the rebuild of their country when this
is all over so i think they
believe and are optimistic that they'll
win this war and push putin back
the thing that sort of strikes me is
that the only reason that we're actually
seeing
the full scale of what's happened is
because russia has been pushed out of
these areas there hasn't effectively
been time for
a cover-up
um in the conversations that you've been
having
what have people been witnessing
i've um
unfortunately i've also been hearing it
firsthand um speaking to ukrainians as
well separately um and it's it's quite
clearly horrendous it's harrowing in
fact um we have family who
can come and live with us but their
their child was in a a uh a bunker a
shelter overnight for several nights in
in kiev and now when he's playing he's
talking about uh
and they're in relative safety right now
but he is uh playing make-believe uh
about building bombshells and can you
hear the bombs outside my my bombshell
and this sort of thing so uh bomb
shelter so you know it's um it's a
horrendous uh picture and and of course
we'll leave many scars but
i should say the determination
from what i've seen of the ukrainian
people and their government to rebuild
the country i mean remarkably the
conversation last night was specifically
organized because he wanted to talk
about how they would get city design
back in to rebuild some of those
flattened cities that you've seen on the
television screens like maripole
and elsewhere and uh which is
extraordinary given the war is still
going on but such is their determination
to
win this and push putin back and i think
they will
um just on the war crimes uh question of
course um do you need to see this do you
think that this all needs to go to the
icc
i think it's absolutely right that this
is all properly documented this matters
we've seen in
in war before it matters that this is
documented uh and that cases are capable
of being bring being brought uh to uh
international justice uh so i think it's
incredibly important almost regardless
what happens in the end that the world
notes
and and frankly you know
we we've seen this i'm afraid we've seen
this behavior from putin now um a number
of different times not just in 2014 in
syria sorry in 2013 in syria but in 2014
uh in in ukraine in crimea uh and
elsewhere so you know it is quite clear
that we we we must document this uh the
world must take note i think it is
and i think it's very very important
that we continue to provide awful some
backing uh to the people of ukraine not
only the people of ukraine but because
the flight to ukraine is roughly the
same as flying to turkey or you know um
greece it
it really is on our doorstep in europe
uh and we all know uh what uh what
happens if if putin doesn't stop there
what is the latest intelligence on the
actual military situation because it
feels like things are quite conflicted
russia reportedly withdrawing from some
areas refocusing on other areas we've
obviously had explosions in the port of
odessa that have come overnight
is russia withdrawing or is it
regrouping
it's more complicated than uh
withdrawing um i mean it is a as ever
with war there's a lot of fog of war but
it's also um the case that this has been
a very disorganized uh campaign we all
saw that the 40 kilometer long uh um
vehicle uh into uh
that was trying to attack from the north
and then that broke apart
um we saw on day one
putin's forces tried to get to a
particular airfield to the northwest of
uh keeping now withdrawn from that
that's gone backwards and forwards lots
of times having said that you only have
to glance at a map uh to see that not
only does uh putin still have the
territory he'd already seized illegally
in 2014
but he's also expanded that around uh
donbass and is desperately trying to
link up his troops and indeed flattening
everywhere in between like merical which
has been largely uh wiped off the the
earth um so it's uh it's a mixed picture
i would say quite clearly not gone to
plan not gone to putin's plan that is uh
and uh and and there is clearly some
some regrouping uh going on but this is
not over by any extent
and
of course the ukrainians
should be able to decide their own
destiny it's not for an outside neighbor
to come in and tell them how they
reorganize their their country
completely unprovoked completely without
warrant attack on their country
let's look now shall we at what we can
actually do uh sanctions of course is
one part of the picture and you
mentioned there the sort of energy
side of this so the eu has spent 18
billion euros on russian oil and gas
since the 24th of february which is when
the war began the russian ruble has
perhaps unsurprisingly given that
recovered nearly all of the losses
incurred since that invasion started i
mean earlier this week you posted a
picture of yourself outside a
confiscated yacht i mean a few
confiscated yachts frankly are not going
to make any difference are they well
europe is bankrolling russia to the tune
of hundreds of millions of dollars every
day
well i think it is first of all it's
absolutely true we may come on to
discuss this the um the price of freedom
and defending democracy in this case and
doing the right thing it doesn't come
cost free i suspect we're going to about
to discuss the cost of living so there's
a flip side to doing all these things
and that is where
more so for europe who are
particularly in countries like germany
readily reliant on russian fuel have
been finding it very difficult to cut
off that fuel now we've said that in the
next nine months i guess eight months
now uh we will stop buying russian fuel
entirely uh none of our petrols from
russia about 18 of our diesel is and
there's some fuel that goes to other
purposes but we have a relatively low
reliance the problem for europe is the
very large amounts as you've just
described being purchased in russian
fuel uh they've said they'll try and cut
that by a third within a year
and all of it eventually it is very very
important we carry on down this route
because as you rightly say you can have
all the sanctions in the world and by
the way i think it is important to
sanction the oligarchs have been very
close to putin which is why i've been
taking uh not just the the super yachts
that you mentioned but several aircraft
including another aircraft this morning
um and freezing them but it is also very
very important that we're not paying
that cash into their system because that
money will go to fund a war effort in
ukraine and you describe the devastation
uh and the human suffering uh in your
opening so it's very very important that
we close that loop britain is urging
countries to go further and faster on
this and again i hear this directly from
my ukrainian counterpart to the british
people he says where the brits go uh
they pioneer and the rest of the world
is following with regard to
providing help and support to ukraine
it's difficult isn't it because as you
say
the sanctions don't come cost free to
people in the uk and i think it's
important to say as well that a lot of
the costs of living issues
were here before the war began but it is
right to say that it's also exacerbated
it you know we're about to see the
biggest fall in living standards since
records began
400 000 more children being pushed into
poverty according to the resolution
foundation i mean these numbers are so
big it's actually hard to get your head
around them
given the fact we're committed to these
sanctions the chancellor is going to
have to come back with more help for
people who are on the red line isn't he
and this is genuinely the flip side of
uh both coming out of korean virus and
seeing the economy take off again the
fastest growing economy in the g7 in
britain last year but also exacerbated
massively by these fuel price increases
which feed through to everything and so
yeah it's very very tough you only have
to look at the price of the pump or the
cost of heating a home and you see the
extent to which the prices have left up
and the chances so far has come forward
with a 22 billion pound uh budget that's
a that's billion not million 22 billion
package to try to assist people uh as we
go through this difficult um period uh
including 9.1 billion a bit which is
specific to the energy side of things we
absolutely want to look to do everything
we can
400 000 more children in poverty i
understand you can't fix everything but
is the chancellor going to have to come
back with more in your opinion
so so um
again i don't want to sort of um uh get
everyone lost in get us lost in numbers
here but poverty is divided into both
absolute and relative um positive and
sometimes uh the way it's presented uh
can uh be somewhat misleading to say the
least what we're trying to do though is
make sure that for example uh if
somebody is working on a minimum
wage for example 16 hours do you need to
come in at this point
because we're seeing 8.7
peak in inflation energy bills are going
up by an astronomical amount it is
absolutely correct to say that there are
many many families in the country up and
down many people watching this program
today who are going to be seriously
worried about how to feed their children
how to heat their homes in the winter my
question is not getting i'm not getting
lost in numbers my question is is the
chance they're going to have to come
back and do more to help these people
because this is what people want to know
they're worried
so so first of all i do not mean to in
any way shape or form uh underplay it
because you don't have to be an expert
you just look at the cost of living
as you mentioned the increase in
inflation um i think equation rpi rather
than cpi but nonetheless it's very
substantial and
that's why the chancellor's already come
forward with 22 billion pounds and i
want to just pick up one figure which is
for quoting rpg
i apologize for quoting rpi rather than
just
i'm glad that you saying that it's fine
that's very reassuring but for the sake
of the people who are very concerned
about how they're going to feed their
children and heat their homes do you
think the chancellor will come back with
more help
well as i said the track record is has
already come forward with a lot of help
including more help just last week no no
no no
sophia if i can just get to there
there's one point i think be helpful for
viewers which is to say
the one thing which has been remarkable
because of the help that was given
during coronavirus is unemployment is
down to 3.9 vacancies are higher than
before coronavirus and more people are
in work than ever before and in the end
that is the way that we're going to most
put money in people's pockets whilst at
the same time making sure that people
will be able to earn all yeah many of
these people are in work though that's
right national insurance
many people are on universal credit uh
in work it's right to say
so as i said i don't want to in any way
shape or form minimize this because it's
it's a very very big serious problem and
you're right to say it's been a global
problem as is that inflation that we're
seeing everywhere throughout the world
however
i was going on before to say that for
somebody who is um on universal credit
because of the way that the chancellor
has amended tapers
uh it means that somebody would be left
with more money in their pockets and the
way that he's amended national insurance
also means that people will end up with
more money in their pocket and that
national insurance change is coming in
very shortly as well so uh we're trying
to do what we can you're asking if we'll
do more i want to i want to absolutely
be clear given the chancellor's record
i'm sure he'll always be looking what
else he can do uh he's already provided
billions and billions of pounds to try
to relieve the pressure and i accept
that we cannot do everything i'd love
for us to be able to absolutely
everything these are global pressures
and one of the best things we can do is
make sure we have a vibrant economy with
very low unemployment
okay we'll be seeing the prime
minister's energy strategy next week
what will be in it to help people who
are worried about how to keep warm it's
really important that we we spread the
variety of ways in which we create
energy uh in this country and indeed in
the world because we've seen what
happens when
somebody like putin gets hold of that
energy supply so next week in the in the
energy strategy we'll be looking for a
greater mix of different ways to produce
our energy uh which do not rely on
imported hydrocarbons there's gas and
oil and side of things particularly from
russia so you might expect to see
more small nuclear reactors nuclear
power you might expect to see more
offshore wind power those i think would
be the things to look for more solar as
well
uh interesting that you're focusing
there on the nuclear and the offshore
wind and of course the issue with
nuclear is that even according to the
government's own impact assessment it
takes 13 to 17 years for an electricity
to be generated by a new nuclear plant
do you think planning law should be
relaxed to allow more onshore wind farms
as well
well just on nuclear um
modular reactors are
likely to be one of the important ways
forward and
you know we've already produced modular
reactors they already exist in in in
subs uh submarines um so i think there
may be other technologies which can be
moved long um faster i i i don't favor a
vast increase in onshore wind farms for
pretty obvious reasons they sit on the
the the hills there and uh can uh create
something of an eyesore for communities
as well as actual problems of noise as
well um so i think for reasons of
environmental protection
the way to go with this is largely not
entirely but largely off sea uh i went
out to a uh to installation
off the northeast coast recently um and
it is incredibly impressive uh not
widely known but britain's got more uh
off c offshore uh wind power than any
other country uh in the world and i
think we could do with expanding that
further still
so just to sort of clarify your
understanding is that the an idea of
like a
big increase in the number of onshore
wind farms that's effectively off the
table for now is it
well i'd urge you to wait for the energy
strategy later in the week but uh
my thinking is what you really want to
do is develop in other ways nuclear
we will have um offshore wind
i don't think you want a huge expansion
of onshore uh when there may be cases
where it where it makes sense but i
think by and large uh we've established
this now that offshore works very well
and by the way it's providing quite a
lot of our electricity already
some in your party would say that the
target to reach net zero emissions by
2050 should be reconsidered in the wake
of the energy crisis that we see as
adita helm professor of energy policy at
oxford university who's recently an
advisor to the prime minister this week
saying that target is hopelessly
unrealistic
do you think that the government is
right to stand by net zero
i think i think in the end um you know
the world faces different threats right
now it's a putin putin from from the
east but you need to
you know we need to know that actually
there are other threats which are going
to destroy us through
or make life very difficult and destroy
communities through uh weather change so
we do need to
tackle climate change uh and actually i
don't think these two things are
particularly incompatible it so happens
that reliance on hydrocarbons uh from
russia are part of what's causing the
global energy
price uh hike so it actually makes sense
to do a switch away from those things uh
and to things which are renewable so i
think over the you know we're talking
about 2050 here not tomorrow so i do
think it's still right to make sure that
we aggressively pursue that and
britain's got a huge lead in this as i
say we've got the biggest wind farms in
the world uh we're leading on a lot of
the different green technologies so for
us it's it's it's new jobs uh which is
very very welcome and great expertise
which we are uh in turn starting to
export so i mean it's i think it's good
business for britain as well
okay i just got a couple of other uh
stories that i'd like to get your
response to um firstly the concert of mp
uh david warburton has had the whip
withdrawn after allegations that were
made against him in a report by the
sunday times now he said that he hasn't
been
contacted by the complaints authority
how are you responding to this
well the party has i think uh withdrawn
the weapon put this under uh the
investigation which needs to go through
its process i don't have any sort of um
further knowledge of it other than what
i've read in the newspapers and what the
parties said um obviously any
allegations like this need to be taken
extremely carefully but all the facts
will need to be um brought out as well
so until we get there i don't think
there's much more i can hopefully add to
it
do you have any concerns about the wider
culture in westminster
well i heard you ask the previous guest
that um uh
i have to say i i don't even know
whether this took place in um
westminster for me it's a an office you
go in you do your job you're in the
chamber uh you get a bite to eat you
carry on with your with your work um
it's certainly not the boozy place that
it that it apparently once was uh many
years ago in my experience i imagine
unless you go and sort the you know seek
these things out and as i say perhaps
not in westminster itself i'm not sure
okay now there's one other thing that i
was keen to ask you about at this
morning and i think you touched on it
slightly earlier in the interview um i
understand you're taking in a family of
ukrainian
refugees um can you tell us a little bit
about the family that you're in contact
with and whether or not they've managed
to make it to the uk yet
yeah uh they are not here yet we're
hoping perhaps in the next week also
they will be uh it's a three generation
family so it's a mother um her mom who's
um 75 a her son who's uh six and their
dog who's called max uh and we're
looking forward to uh to welcome him
here uh we um they've been um getting
ready to to to leave um and uh we we're
excited to to have them in our home
what's been the reason for
the delay in getting them to your house
the mum was traveling on a um they they
they fled i mentioned about them being
at a bomb shelter uh for several nights
and they fled out of keeve uh reached uh
they're in uh krakow right now in poland
uh the mum only has a national what they
call a national passport it's like an id
card not a
um not not a full international passport
and so as she has to she has had to
visit a visa office whereas the others
are able to travel without the uh
without having traveled to a visa office
um and then there was the complication
of the pet although i think we are keen
to remove those complications as well uh
because it looked like the dog may have
to might have at one point had to
quarantine for four months and i think
uh i think there are moves of foot to
prevent that from happening so i mean
it is important they're very
understanding that you do need to know
who is coming to the country and it's
not beyond putin and his cronies to
deceive uh brits by sending people to
live in in in the uk uh who may have
you know the wrong the wrong motivations
uh but uh it it does look to me like
it's coming to the towards the end of
the process and i think they're looking
at booking we hope within the next week
or so to join us
the whole family is very excited we're
looking forward to them um staying with
us it will be a bit of a squeeze but we
will make it work and um and we're
you know delighted to be able to do a do
a small a small thing here and quickly
before i have to let you go the latest
figures show that i think 32 000 people
have applied for a visa under the home's
view crohn's scheme only 4700
have been issued do you have an update
on those figures and are they actually
good enough yeah so i mean look i i
think we're going to see this um cranked
up fairly quickly just overall 29 100
people have received visas under both
the schemes not just the homes for
ukraine scheme so 29 000 people just
over i think we'll see the numbers with
the homes for ukraine that's where
families like mine are bringing in uh
ukrainian families to come and live with
us we found ours through facebook i
should say i don't know the family at
all uh and um and of course there are
some necessary checks before they before
they come over but i think we'll see
those numbers expand very quickly and
it's unlimited it's not capped so you
know and i tend to think of them not as
refugees but really as evacuees because
they want to go home
they want to return and rebuild their
country in the case of the family that
we're having uh the husband is um is
still in in in ukraine so very very keen
of course they they'll be to get back to
him as well
okay thank you very much for your time
this morning grant chapster thank you
well while so much of the focus is quite
rightly on the conflict in ukraine there
is still a packed domestic agenda as
well often with links of course to that
war on the other side of europe well
this week we should get the prime
minister's much vaunted strategy on
energy security we've been discussing it
on the show this morning um grant shap's
giving his opinion on wind farms also of
course you're expecting more nuclear
solar more north sea oil and gas and of
course the return as well potential well
i was going to say the return to new
onshore wind but maybe that's not
actually going to happen so um we'll
have to wait and see for that one well
meanwhile of course there is still lots
of concern about how quickly ukrainian
refugees are being giving visas to enter
the united kingdom so we're joined now
by the conservative mp for rutland and
melton alicia kearns thank you so much
for being with us
we were just talking to grant shapster
about uh refugees he's hoping to get
some ukrainian family of ukrainian
family into his home and i know that
you've been involved in pairing
ukrainian families to people in your
constituency and also fellow mps
how have you found honestly how have you
found the system to navigate
so
the frustration is you have to know
ukrainians to be able to match with them
the good news is because i have the
privilege of working with the most
amazing group of ukrainian mps they've
matched me with i think i think so far
i've matched 26
ukrainian families to i think 20 homes
in my constituency and then another five
or six families to uh british mps who
are willing to take people into their
homes and it has been a mixed picture i
have one visa that was applied for on
the monday and came through by the
tuesday afternoon um i've got another
visa that has been in the system now for
10 days um
the frustration is obviously we still
need to go faster and further in terms
of making sure people can apply in their
own language and that we get these
things done quickly but when i speak to
ukrainian mps actually they're saying we
want you to do security checks because
we want this to work and there is a
difference to other schemes and that we
are inviting people into british
people's homes so there is a there is a
duty of care there to make sure this is
going to work um but so far we've got a
number of people arriving tomorrow and i
think we're all very much looking
forward to working them into our homes
i do
totally recognize the duty of care when
people are coming into individuals homes
from both sides from the uk side but
also from the ukrainian family side as
well
but should the visa process be at least
changed in some way to allow people to
get out of ukraine as quickly as they
can and then some of the bureaucracy can
be done when they're here in the united
kingdom
we all want this to move as quickly as
possible i think the scenes we're seeing
from bucca and from mario paul make
clear that there are war crimes taking
place and we want people out as soon as
possible the vast majority of ukrainians
that i've been matching with my
constituents are actually already out of
ukraine so they are applying from
hungary or from germany or from poland
and places like that so
do you
know that ukrainians are getting out
safely and now we just need to get them
to the uk okay um a couple of issues
with the signal there but i think it
should be okay now so we're going to
keep going and we were talking about the
energy strategy as well and this of
course links into the cost of living a
crisis has been stories in the
newspapers today about up to seven new
nuclear stations and it was interesting
listening to grant shapso he was pretty
firm on the idea of onshore wind saying
it was an eyesore that's not something
that he could support and do you think
that the government is right to be
moving away from onshore wind
so i think the offshore wind is the
greatest opportunity that we have in
terms of energy and i know that the
prime minister's spoken before about
being the saudi arabia of wind you know
we have the celtic sea i think that's
where we should be investing the
majority of our wind focus uh in terms
of onshore wind i'm probably one of the
only people in the country that thinks
that uh onshore wind is actually quite
beautiful in its own way uh but i
recognize that i don't probably
represent the majority there so i think
offshore wind should absolutely be our
priority and that also allows us to move
away from our reliance on these
dangerous solar farm supply chains where
too many of the companies are bound up
in the genocide we're seeing of the
uyghur
at the same time though it's probably
right to declare your own interest i
mean you've campaigned to stop a solar
farm in your constituency
is this not part of the issue though
that you know
if we are going to get energy security
and an energy supply that is going to
heat people's homes and securely
someone's going to have to live near
solar farms onshore wind farms nuclear
power stations as well i mean how are
you going to square that
we already have uh solar plants in
rutland mountain and we will have more
solar plants in rotten developed in the
future but what i won't accept is having
a company such as canadian solar who
have been they've had some of their
suppliers sanctioned by the us
government they've had four shipments of
their solar plants to the us taken off
them because they have been proven now
including by report by the university of
sheffield to be complicit in the
genocide of the weaker people i will not
have uh bloodstained solar panels
essentially pollute our environment
there are alternatives to polysilicon
that can go into solar panels there's a
great piece of work done at loughborough
university there are companies that are
producing these solar panels now without
polysilicon so we can clean up our
supply chains we can stop using the
cheap uyghur slave labor that is making
the vast majority of solar panels around
the country in the world at the moment
but that's a choice and a decision we
have to make so i'm not saying no to
solar quite the opposite i'm saying we
want cleaner solar and solar that isn't
cheap for us because it's built in the
blood and slave labor of others
now i want to talk to you a bit about
maternity care in the united kingdom you
know
and just sort of speaking frankly for a
minute you know on a sunday show you're
often looking to throw forward to
stories that are happening next week
like the energy security strategy and
but i actually want to just take a
moment and speak about a story that i i
found extremely personally affecting
this week
and it is this
story that 201 babies and nine mothers
died as a result of failings at the
shores b and telford nhs trust i mean
we're talking about the deaths of more
than 200
babies and i know that you're someone
who's spoken out about maternity care
before
can we really say the uk is a safe place
for women to give birth in
i think
i think that reports
the anger and the heartbreak that i have
felt and clearly you have felt and so
many ass has felt
i have to say that as an mp over the
last two and a half years i have sadly
had to conclude that nhs bureaucracies
are inherently and systematically sexist
there is a constant expectation that
women services and care can be done on
the cheap or that because women have
given birth for generations and
generations they don't deserve the
support they need and my mother saw me
speak out in parliament and actually she
said to me that she remembered when she
was giving birth to my brother and she
asked for a c-section no i like she
asked for an epidural and because she'd
been in labor for so many days and so
many in so much pain and she remembers
being screamed at by the consultant and
told you think you're special you're not
special women do this every day
again i shared my own experience of
having a c-section i ended up being
taken to the operating theatre twice
because they weren't willing to give me
the c-section that i needed when i'd
been in labor 36 hours and my son had
already almost died once because of this
obsession with stats and low c-section
rates and also this idea that there is a
normal birth there is no such thing as
the births that we see in movies some
women have amazing birth stories that
these should not be expected of all
women um and i do worry that we have
seen it be very unsafe over the last two
years as we saw the campaign that you
and i spoke about a lot about partners
being locked up the room that made women
less safe so i think we have a way to go
but i think anyone who's watching this
is about to go into labor
know that our hospitals are safe but you
need to know that you have every right
to challenge the system and to say at
any point wait know why what are the
alternatives and why are you doing this
it is your body and you have a right to
challenge and demand better and demand
what you need to keep you safe
i think this is exactly it isn't it it's
this feeling that
what happened at sheridan telford is the
the worst example of when the system
goes wrong but every woman and many
women listening to this program or all
their mothers or their sisters or their
friends will have their own stories of
birth not going in the way that they
wanted of losing control of the birth
and of not feeling safe or supported and
i think it as you say it goes back to
that thing about women being listened to
what needs to change going forward and
what can the government do to try and
make the situation better or less sexist
as you say
i think sajid is exactly the man to deal
with this he cares deeply about fighting
for women's rights he cares deeply about
families and supporting them and i know
that he has been personally found it
very hard seeing the conclusions of this
report and how much women and families i
mean people lives were lost and that
heartache and pain that people went
through is something that they will
still be living with today
and so i have absolute confidence that
sergeant is going to make sure maternity
system gets what it needs he's given it
the biggest investment of funds that i
think it's ever seen
and i believe truly that if there is a
health secretary that will fight for it
it is sadjid and he will make sure that
women's voices are listened to and he
has committed to looking around the
country to make sure that we don't see
something like this again
okay thank you for talking so openly
about um about what happened and your
own experiences as well and just finally
you've been um on the uh gay conversion
therapy ban i was just keen to try and
unpick what exactly happened
this week first the prime minister said
it was gonna be banned then he
backtracked then he was contacted by 60
mps i believe including yourself um and
then he said you would it would be bad
can you just unpick what exactly went on
because it looks pretty shambolic from
someone on the outside
um look obviously i don't work in number
10 i i don't know exactly what happened
but i do know that when i got elected i
went to the prime minister and said we
need to ban conversion therapy it is
wrong it tells every gay and trans
person in this country that they don't
deserve to be loved that they have some
sort of pathology that can be cured and
that is wrong and he was he was really
surprised that it was still legal
because when he was mayor of london he
banned the advertising conversion
therapy on the tube because he
recognized how wrong and dangerous it
was so in all my conversations with him
he has backed this ban entirely it was
in the last queen speech um and then yes
on friday we saw this leaked document
that suggests the government was going
to drop the ban
um and i think colleagues very
rightfully made clear to the prime
minister and to everyone else within the
system how strongly they felt that this
cannot continue within our country we
will not allow gay and trans people to
feel attacked threatened and unsafe in
our country by allowing this legislation
to well essentially this appalling
quackery and fraudulent activity to
continue in our country and the good
thing now is that the promise has been
cleared the ban will go forward um but
for me now it's about making sure it is
the right ban and that crucially we
don't say that trans people will be
excluded from this ban because they are
vulnerable
and when people want to criticize this
bill i would say very clearly if you are
arguing that there's not enough critical
conversations taken with young people
who are questioning their gender
identity then you should back this bill
because this bill says if you are
questioning your sexuality or your
gender identity then when you want to
have these challenging critical and safe
conversations they should take place
with a regulated and accredited
individual not a quack not a woke hippie
around the corner someone who will
genuinely work with you and support you
through this process that should be what
we want for all of our children and we
should want to send a very clear message
that everyone in this country deserves
to be loved and that being who you are
is never a pathology
okay thank you for being on the program
today we are out of time thank you
well let's return to ukraine now shall
we and the reports coming in from
ukraine this morning are truly shocking
and indeed heartbreaking and
as i said we haven't shown the full
horror of what is coming in but we're
talking about dead bodies strewn across
streets
people next to bicycles and with
shopping bags these are areas retaken
from russian forces as they leave the
areas around kiev in the north of
ukraine
and
well as we've been saying that
absolutely horrendous meanwhile the red
cross is once again attempting to take
aid into the besieged city of mariopol
in the south
well let's get a voice from ukraine now
shall we elon ishgram is a ukrainian
member of parliament she's a lawyer and
a human rights activist she's currently
in paris after having met with the
french president and she joins us now
live um thank you so much for being on
the program firstly how was your meeting
with emmanuel macron and are you
satisfied with what he said to you
um
well good morning also we do not say
good morning anymore in ukraine um but
yeah it is very important for us now to
give personal
uh you know evidence on what is going on
in kiev in kharkiv in other cities we
did have a meeting with uh macron and we
were four members of parliament and
women battalion which we call ourselves
now
and also a mayor of melitopol uh who was
captured and who was uh taken hostage
for six days and then was exchanged for
nine russian soldiers so he he told his
experience in being in captivity uh how
was he treated what did they want how he
was forced to resign obviously he did
not resign and i think it was incredibly
important for french people for french
politicians and for the french president
to hear
and to hear it from somebody who is not
resume but who's been there two days ago
just there in kiev uh as to how
successful it was
uh well we will see obviously on the
results
we you know we ukraine is pretty much
done with diplomacy we have been very
straightforward we have been very direct
and i will tell you very honestly if
something that macron promised he did
not deliver
but i hope that he will deliver on every
point that we talked about
um i'm very keen to talk about the
individual stories of what's happening
in ukraine but just firstly on macron um
europe and the eu is of course spending
hundreds of millions of pounds every day
on russian
oil and particularly gas
is that acceptable
no it's not acceptable and actually that
question was raised obviously with
president macron and he said that yes
they are ready to do an embargo on
russian oil and gas
they have denied paying in rubles
for it as you know uh as as did a lot of
other members of the european union and
we asked macron specifically as a
president or right now as he is the
president of france's presidency in
europe to work with other countries uh
and to work on the unity basically
because if the europe will not be united
then putin will for sure become stronger
and stronger and we do need to stop the
putin
today and together
that is why it was very important to
talk to france after actually our visit
to great britain as you may know
just to clarify president macron told
you that he was prepared to do an
embargo on russian
oil and gas he said that he's prepared
yes to go through if would be needed yes
and do you believe him do you believe
his assurance
um well yesterday we were also you know
at the manifestation because ukrainians
and french people gather in paris in the
place de la republique every saturday
for the manifestations to actually put a
pressure on french politicians to stop
buying russian gas to stop buying
russian oil uh to stop putting russian
cargo ships
to the french ports
uh and and basically to force the
companies which are french companies to
go outside of russia and i think that
this pressure is the main important
pressure why it will work so i'm sure
that actually those manifestations those
meetings um those hundreds of thousands
of people that go every saturday they
are the ones who actually will force it
through till the end
and this is why i am much more
optimistic
you i mentioned there that you were
joined by the mayor who was captured by
russian forces and i think many of us
will remember uh that story of them
taking the mayor and
what exactly did happen to him and how
was he treated
oh
it's obviously better to ask him but
yeah his story is incredible because um
well basically he he had the possibility
to communicate was the one who captured
him right so he had the possibility to
ask some questions and to get the
answers because he was there for a while
basically what they wanted from him they
wanted him to resign uh or to
collaborate with them or to appoint a
deputy mayor that would be from the
russian soldier's side and obviously he
did not do that
as far as i understand they were too
scared to actually kill him or torture
him because his case got to the very
highest level and putin knew about his
case personally uh but he's saying that
he was asking them all the time why did
you come to my city and why do you want
to do that and the answers he got were
well incredible from the russian
propaganda side because they would say
that you know
we want to liberate you from the nazi
regime and he was like well i'm 33 years
old i have never seen one nothing in
ukraine what else and they would say
well we know that you uh kill and bully
veterans of the second world war on the
streets and he would be like well there
are 34 veterans alive of the second
world war in my city milital and i am in
constant contact with them and bring
them food you know and then and medicine
and anything they need so this kind of
propaganda talks have been going for
days and he was trying to as i
understand
well convince them on something but it
was it was an incredible thing how the
russian soldiers at the time were you
know propaganda brainwashed and what did
they think would happen
you say that they were too scared to
kill him or to torture or harm him
of course that is not something that is
afforded to so many of the ukrainian
civilians and this morning we've seen
what has been left after russian forces
retreated from areas around kiev
can you just explain to our viewers the
kind of things that people of ukraine
are witnessing
um well right now unfortunately we have
another city which has been uh destroyed
as mario paul was it's called izum
uh in translation from ukraine from
ukraine and it's raisin so it's supposed
to be something you know uh nice and uh
and and and
um well and food-like but there is no
food right now in in raisin or in zoom
uh it's been destroyed by eighty percent
i think it's becoming the next mario
ball which is a horrifying news for us
to hear it's also in the east of ukraine
um there is no food
people have been forced well to stay
underground without food and water as
mario were people are not being able to
escape
and basically this humanitarian
catastrophe that putin is putting on
ukraine continues
we actually did raise a number of
questions
about the international red cross
because you know that the presence of
international red cross was not there on
the ground in those horrible situations
to help people
we want either red cross to be much more
present either we want to recross to
make a statement why they are not
present because personally in personal
conversations they say that russia is
not allowing them to be present and is
not accepting their diplomatic immunity
but they are not making a public
statement about that and this is
something which is horribly wrong with
international law and with international
order
so i really hope that international red
cross would go more public
and would be much more helpful for the
people who are there who are in the
worst possible situation right now in
the middle of europe three hours from us
right now
not having food not having water not
knowing whether there would be a life
tomorrow um living in horrible in in
absolutely horrible conditions of fear
pain no medicine nothing delivered and
not been able to go you know to another
city in ukraine and this is something
which
is shocking for me even on the 39 days
of war i still i still don't get how did
we allow this to happen
it's horrific situation people just as
you say trapped with no food no water
in the worst possible situation thank
you so much for coming on the program we
value your voice and thank you
thank you thank you
well the war is also having a big impact
on health care more widely of course in
ukraine and with modern drugs people
with hiv live long full healthy lives
but without those drugs their health and
very lives are at stake now ukraine has
got some of the highest prevalence rates
of hiv in the world outside of africa as
much as one percent of the entire
population has the virus and it was
already struggling with the burden of
hiv now of course with drug supplies
disrupted after the invasion support for
those living with hiv tb and other
serious conditions has effectively
collapsed
we're joined uh now by the alliance for
public health executive director andre
klepikov you were based in kiev you're
now in la viv in the west of the country
thank you for being with us
it's always so critical for us to hear
from people on the ground in ukraine and
we've seen these horrific images this
morning
of
what's happened to civilians can you
just start by giving us a sense of the
situation
on the ground in ukraine and what people
are witnessing
good morning yes uh situation is very
terrible because we saw a huge tragedy
in in bucha in the kiev sabah
russians
actually practice genocide killing
men between the age of 18 and 16.
and of course uh if we are talking about
people with hiv wisdom people who use
drugs they were vulnerable even in a
normal life so during the war their
vulnerability increased by times
uh and most of the people living with
hiv actually located an eastern and
southern part of ukraine
affected the war the most
as you say you know ukraine has got a
very serious hiv epidemic i think more
than 250 000 people living with the
virus
just give us a sense of how difficult it
is to get these crucial drugs to those
who need them
it is a very challenging task because in
the areas directly affected by the war
over 100 000 people with hiv are living
59 000 out of them are receiving
antiretroviral treatment
so it's not only governmental uh
agencies medical facilities but also
ngos like mine uh delivering irv drugs
to the patients
it is difficult and it's very
challenging because we are continuing to
do this events in the occupied
territories
unfortunately it's dangerous uh and just
couple of days ago
our partner organization faced situation
where
a van with volunteers delivering
medicines and humanitarian aid was
shelled and two people unfortunately
died
really awful to hear that
aid workers people who are delivering
essential medical supplies coming under
fire can you give us a bit more
information about what happened with
that attack or is it impossible for you
to do so
uh it was
attack intentional attack because
clearly
there was
clearly not a military convoy it was
humanitarian convoy it was clearly
visible and it was attacked on the way
to convoy to chernigev
that's the situation our partner
organization faced and this is our van
which was destroyed but uh destructions
are huge all
over all
areas including mariupol where uh uh all
locations were destroyed to dust
actually to nothing clinics in nikolai
were destroyed in kharkiv in the zoom
which was already mentioned
by
mp colleague from ukraine
terrible things are going on and
civilians medical personnel social
workers are suffering more and more from
this war
have you been able to get supplies into
mario paul and i think there are almost
5 000 people living with hiv there or is
the situation just too difficult and too
dangerous to get those supplies in
unfortunately russian forces
don't allow to go in so we helped those
patients who managed to escape and now
move to nipro or the parisia or other
locations
but unfortunately access to mariupol is
so difficult we are helping some people
even known with hiv but for example
suffers from this
terrible attack on on
on shelter
located in theater
it wasn't the news and uh
there were terrible stories so we helped
people to evacuate from from there hiv
positive and not hiv positive we in this
situation we are helping everyone
yeah you're in the business of saving
lives right so that's what you do as a
organization such as yourself
what stories are you hearing from the
people that you are meeting in these
desperate situations
needs of people uh increased
substantially
now they are requiring not only
medications but also
food
housing or shelter
some support psychological support
mental health support
so
we need more resources
and we are having this
appeal hosted by organization
frontline aides so
please call in to everyone to to support
us with with checking the website
frontlineage.org
donate
it's important to provide more resources
because so far our resources are limited
and we are working in all provinces of
ukraine
uh
more than
with 100
local organizations based on the ground
how many people are at risk of running
out of the drugs that they need and as a
result can you put any
figure on the number of lives that could
be at risk
risk is very high it's the highest i
think in the world so if we are talking
about uh
hiv patients as i said uh 59 000 people
are on irt in the areas affected by the
war and uh
less than uh 40 percent managed to move
outside uh of of these war zones so we
are talking about uh
tens of thousands of people at risk
we use different uh modalities to
deliver drugs where it's possible
through mobile vents through smaller
delivery even through
mail where it's possible
but the key things is the logistics
because uh unfortunately in some places
like to mario paul access is restricted
tens of thousands of people at risk
thank you for coming on the program and
speaking so powerfully
it's one of those consequences of the
war isn't it that perhaps you may not
initially think about but so many lives
at stake so thank you for coming on the
programme today
well that is it for this week's safety
rage on sunday but don't go anywhere
because in a moment after the break
we're going to be running through
today's interviews and having a look at
what we've learned we're joined by our
deputy political editor sam coats thank
you for joining us this sunday
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
b
[Music]
so
[Music]
hello welcome to safety ridge on sunday
the take a moment where we can reflect
and give some of our own thoughts on
what we've just heard over the last hour
on safety ridge on sunday well among our
guests this sunday where the transport
secretary grant shaps and also labour's
shadow business secretary jonathan
reynolds of course high on the agenda
was ukraine after some of those
appalling images that we've seen
coming out of the areas around kiev as
russian troops withdrew from the country
lots of questions about the
international community's response to
that when it comes to refugees when it
comes to sanctions when it comes to the
supply of weapons um but we were also
talking about on the show about the
domestic agenda as well because there's
a very big
energy strategy coming up next week it's
a significant one it would top our
program in any other
circumstances because it's one of those
kind of long delayed strategies it does
feel as if there is a bit of dispute
going on around the cabinet table on the
best way
forward to manage the uk's energy supply
so at this point we can bring in our
deputy political editor shall we uh sam
coates
who is with us this morning uh from uh
not the garden today but uh you ventured
inside i can see uh sam good to have you
with us um
i was quite interested actually with the
grant chapter interview because i felt
we learned a bit more than i was
expecting actually on the energy
strategy he was pretty scathing
about the idea of onshore at wind farms
and it feels to me as if there's been a
lot of movement going on behind the
scenes on this in the last couple of
weeks so what's your
take on where we've ended up with it
well i think the energy strategy is a
big moment because
for much of boris johnson's time in
number 10 there have been
monumental epic crises dominating his
time first brexit than the pandemic and
then the war in ukraine but when the
spotlight's gone back on to domestic
matters everything's turned out to be
more tricky and i just wonder whether or
not this week on thursday when we're
expecting the energy strategy that isn't
uh one of them because there have been
there are divisions now i think you pick
up on exactly the right point as
recently as last week quasi quatting
he's the business secretary was wanting
a huge increase in the amount of onshore
wind in order to wean us off kind of
international oil and gas provide
sustainable renewable forms of energy so
that we're not as exposed to ice
price hikes of the sort that we're
getting as a result of uh what's going
on in russia and ukraine
but it looks as if that has proved too
unpopular quasi-quarten wanted to double
onshore wind production by 2030 triplet
by 2035 but the language sophie this
morning is very different number 10 have
said that onshore wind this morning is
now subject to the consent of
communities and grant chaps on your
program has called it an eyesore very
very different type of ambition
well let's have a listen to that grant
chat's grab shall we when he does say
that word the eyesore because it is
pretty punchy language we can have a
listen now
modular reactors are likely to be one of
the important ways forward and um you
know we have already produced modular
reactors they they already exist in in
subs uh submarines um so i think there
may be other technologies which can be
moved
faster i i i don't favor a vast increase
in onshore uh wind farms um for pretty
obvious reasons they sit on the
the the hills there and uh can uh create
something of an eyesore
something of an eyesore a very strong
language there from uh grant chaps and
actually it's interesting because it
does feel as if many of the you know
conservative ministers that i interview
on the show have been moving in the same
direction nadine's a hallway again last
week
was
talking perhaps not in quite as flowery
language about the wind farms but
certainly making clear that he was
uncomfortable with the idea of them
being built
without community consent so you can get
a sense of where cabinet is pushing the
prime minister the other big question of
course is how much emphasis should be
placed
on the target for net zero and for green
energy energy supplies or the oil and
gas perhaps that makes up i think around
50 of the uk's energy uh supplies so you
know that those are big questions for
grant chapter he stuck by the net zero
target and i put the same thing to
jonathan reynolds at labour's
spokesperson what is more important is
that the country's net zero targets or
reducing people's energy bills or can
you do both here's what mr reynolds had
to say
there's no point this country having a
ambitious climate strategy if we're not
going to stick to it and of course even
if people face
huge
huge like difficulties with paying their
bills even if people are having to turn
off their health let's be clear more
domestic supply is about the security of
that supply it's not about the price the
price is set by the global market price
for that so even if we for instance
wanted to go down the route of
extracting a fundamentally large amount
of oil and gas from the uk that wouldn't
affect the price the only way to affect
the price is to focus on energy
efficiency so people are using less is
to switch to uh domestic cheaper
electrification of heating so it's very
important people understand that point
uh that was uh jonathan reynolds uh
there well let's bring uh sam back in
shall we uh sam
you can sense where the prime minister
has been walked when it comes to onshore
wind is there similar pressure over net
zero or do you think that he still has a
support
of his party there
there is pressure on boris johnson over
that net zero from his back benches
but at the moment he does remain
committed also we are told boris johnson
always capable of a u-turn uh of course
but because you can see an argument this
is an argument that boris johnson
believes in that more renewables means
more security of supply which is how
you can deal with the problems for
instance that you're seeing with an
increase in uh oil prices from uh
because of what's going on in russia uh
there is a logic to the prime minister's
position and logic to the prime minister
sticking firm the question i think for
this energy strategy will be whether or
not if not onshore wind which would be i
think uh much more part of labor's
alternative then what you heard grant
chaps talk about the answer being
modular nuclear power stations now there
is uh a plan of seven new uh or
modular as they would have it in some
cases uh power stations opening up
between now and 2050. so i think the
question is can you nuclear pack come on
stream fast enough i thought the most
intriguing bit of what grant shap said
to you sophie
was that of course modular technology
would be fine because we already have it
in nuclear submarines
in other words is not currently working
generating power for domestic
consumption for business consumption in
the way that we normally have and that
suggests that there's still some way to
go with development so the question is
is this strategy going to provide the
electricity we need soon enough or could
it still raise questions about where
we're going to get supply uh in the
coming years yeah this is the point
isn't it it's the time frame of this and
people are going to be looking at their
bills right now and thinking oh my
goodness how on earth am i going to
afford to you know heat my house
in the winter and of course we you know
as jonathan reynolds were saying it's
it's not necessarily the case that the
supply is linked directly to prices but
if people are looking at nuclear power
stations that will take you know decades
to to build and to to get into power
surely the government needs to be
talking as well would you say
things that are
much more immediate
that's right and there is no easy way of
turning on the taps of different power
supplies perhaps without restarting some
of the fossil fuel
options that you've got which may come
on thursday but
can't frankly happen for very a great
deal of time
but i think the cost of living pressures
have changed the dynamic in this debate
and it was fascinating to watch grant
chats uh answer some of those questions
or if i may be so bold not really answer
uh them when it came to being challenged
about the pressures that families
incredible pressures that families are
facing at the moment he quibbled with
the definition of poverty for children
in poverty he quibbled with quite how
you measure rising prices these don't
feel like the answers of a government
that's completely nailed uh the biggest
question domestically of our time which
is how on earth are big people going to
cope with energy bills going through the
roof prices going through the roof a
cold snap all of a sudden that's leaving
many people not turning uh on their
heating uh and this being the number one
issue facing the government at the
moment yeah i think i was particularly
surprised to hear him quibble with the
8.7 peak of inflation when that is the
numbers that we were given uh in the
actual spring statement itself but there
you go and sam thank you very much for
being with us on the program uh we will
hear more from you after the break
because we're going to be talking about
grant chapter's plans to take in a
ukrainian family into his home
[Music]
big stories don't always come from big
cities
i'm lisa dowd and i'm sky's midlands
correspondent and this is where i grew
up
we can reveal that the driver who hit
harry dunn is 42 year old and sir coolas
just met the president and
we never thought we'd get this far this
is what they're up against that the wind
is the really big problems it is back
breaking work and the smoke is thick
[Music]
it's been working well water levels are
dropping but no one knows what impact
further rain will have
what would you do if this place wasn't
open
we take you to the heart of the stories
that shape our world
it's really scary we're terrified
in this community i'm told that
everybody knows someone affected by
covid hopefully this will be the last
wave
i never knew they would make it it's
amazing
the change seems tantalisingly close in
this corner of the uk
wales was the first to introduce the
plastic bag charge
this is my patch my specialism it's also
my home
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello welcome back to safety ridge on
sunday the take where we take you back
through the morning's interviews and
some analysis as well from me and our
deputy political editor sam coates well
there's been lots of focus of course on
ukraine uh some of those heart-rending
images coming out of that country onto
what is happening to civilians there
will no doubt redouble uh the calls for
the uk to speed up the refugee program
the homes for ukraine scheme for example
where many more people have applied than
have currently got visas now the
transport secretary the guest on the
show this morning grant shaps is going
to be hosting a ukrainian family of
three a six-year-old boy his mother and
his 75 year old grandmother alongside
their dog max who apparently is causing
a few complications with the uh process
that he was telling us earlier
i was asking him to try and explain why
there's been a delay in their arrival
let's have a listen
they are not here yet we're hoping
perhaps in the next week also they will
be uh it's a three-generation family so
it's a mother um her mom who's um 75 a
her son who's uh six and their dog who's
called max uh and we're looking forward
to uh to welcome him here uh we um
they've been um
getting ready to to to to leave um and
uh we we're excited to to have them in
our home
uh grant chaps there talking about his
own experience with that system well
let's talk to sam coach shall we um it's
interesting isn't it you know the person
often reflects the uh political grant
chaps has been talking about this family
for a little while but they still
haven't managed to make it
to the united kingdom we were also
speaking to alicia kearns on the
programme
as well who's been matching up families
and she says that yes some people are
getting here very quickly but for other
people it's taking you know up to
several weeks for the applications to be
processed how much pressure is there on
the government to speed things up
um there's there's quite a lot of
pressure it's not hard to find people
who are willing to get stuck in and
criticize the home office for the way
that they've gone about uh there's a
bureaucracy of the home office for the
way that they're going about processing
uh the various visa applications there's
also got to be checks on the individuals
like grant chaps to check that they are
fit and proper people let's hope he
passes that test uh in order to take in
a family
um but what's interesting i think grant
chaps is the pretty much the first most
high profile cabinet mister to come out
and say that he will uh take in some
ukrainian uh refugees
uh uh
and he is um proudly talking about that
he refers uh to the
to the to the playing of the
six-year-olds the fact that the
six-year-old plays and while he's doing
so uh he talks about making make-believe
bomb shelters so grant chapter who had a
ukrainian flag in the back of his
interview uh when he was talking to you
uh who talked regularly to his
counterpart in ukraine uh the transport
minister also now um getting clearly
quite involved with this family uh of
three plus the dog uh who are going to
come and live with him uh really putting
making clear his commitment to the
ukrainian issue but that doesn't lessen
some of the pressure on the home office
to get things like these cases sorted
out
i think that
nevertheless a decision has been taken
by the pretty much the whole of the
british political system unchallenged
that there do need to be visas for
ukrainians coming to the uk the pressure
is on speeding that up because other
countries aren't requiring a visa in
order to uh enter their seek refuge uh
in those countries and that's the big
difference between the uk uh and some
european countries that's the thing
that's causing some of the time uh and
as grant chap said uh one of the people
coming to stay with him is having to
go to a visa processing center in order
to sort out their documentation because
they only had effectively the ukrainian
equivalent uh of an id card but i
suspect sophie that what we're going to
hear in the coming weeks and months
is
different evolutions and uh and
controversies involving this uh refugee
scheme uh one of its most notable
features is that really it provides for
people to come to stay for six months
and as grant shap said it would make
every logical bit of sense for the
family that's coming to stay with him to
go back because the father
of the child is uh over in ukraine
presumably stayed to defend the country
as they
as as men of a certain age are obligated
to do
but there is no clearly no certainty
about what is going to happen next to
ukraine quite how this is going to end
even though there are some signs uh that
the russian government is abandoning
attempts to take the whole country
and to catch a keeve
and does that mean that the families
that come here on a promise of being
able to come for six months stay after
six months or go after six months or
what happens to them then there's a
certain plan assuming a certain duration
of the conflict in place here in the uk
and even those like grandchats who are
hosting families don't quite know what's
going to happen uh in
threes in six nine 12 months to the
people that they are promising to put up
now okay uh really interesting to talk
as always uh sam and it feels as well
like you know we're often very cynical
with stuff like this uh on the programme
but fair play to grant chaps he has
made contact with his family he's opened
up his house
and he does seem to be the first cabinet
minister to have made those concrete
plans that's it for this week
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you